if God is telling us to worship Him
alone Satan's job is gonna be what the
whole of us yeah so this is where we're
saying maybe it's a show do you not
think as a Muslim that our Christian
friends have fallen for the trap of
Satan for sure
sure how is it that I can be good enough
for God well I can't because goddess of
God's holy mountain in the sense of how
can I be a pure infinity and in that
sense there's the concept of imputed
righteousness okay
his Jesus fully good yes is he fully man
so a lot of people watching this would
be like how sure check our sponsors and
natures blend they specialize in premium
Ethiopian black seed products their
products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the Sunnah the
website is in the description link below
you can also use the discount code Salam
10 for 10% of their products but what
would see is that for example because
god almighty is is this force and he's
infinite and there is nothing like him
there is no comparison to him so why
seeing Christianity is that God man is
mortal man is fire finite Bono mites is
infinite yeah and there's something in
between which is Jesus which is Ria's is
is man but it's also good so it's like
and this is where exactly we believe in
Islam there there is no we don't need it
so there is no need for and that's the
reason why Islam came now when I say
Salaam came Islam has been there from
day one we believe from Adam peace be
upon him chill Prophet Muhammad Islam
has been there in the context of Islam's
main purpose is to come and tell people
to stop worshipping idols and gods and
attributing God's attributes to mankind
because that's the main fundamental in
Islam has come to do and what as human
beings we do is because we worship God
Almighty and it's not something that we
can empirically see happens is as human
beings we tend to want to see but when
we're grateful to people is because we
we see the things they're doing for us
so we're like okay you know what thank
you we thank God but the fingers because
we can't see him and I saw chest of life
yeah you worshiping him without him
seeing so that's why you see a lot of
people be the pagans be it for example
agree on that yeah yeah if you see them
for example that were they done oh like
the pagan Arabs would say the same thing
we believe God also a power we just use
these statues to get closer to him so
what happens is you feel inferior I'm a
sinner I don't know how can I talk to
someone that God is pure I know if I can
go through someone else who's done the
job or his closer this is where yeah
Satan she tricks us because what it does
is we want to see something
empirically ok that's a statue I can
touch I'm gonna feel then yeah it gives
me good powers of some people who carry
certain things like oh yeah for good
luck
do I because this is exactly but as
human beings go what God is telling us
is have trust in me you can't see me but
I'm with you and knows it's you then
your jugular vein so what Islam has come
to say is look you do not to require it
does it doesn't necessarily require for
you to have another person who is divine
because firstly it doesn't go without
fits wrong because the Trinity for
example if I was to say to you okay
is Jesus fully good yes is he fully man
yes so a lot of people watching this
would be like how sure you can share the
same so in that context what we're
saying is make the same argument and you
search I mean I can explain I think the
necessity of these positions but just as
much as the Quran and I think the Bible
and the Quran both the times appeal to
mystery I do believe actually the word
mystery is invented by the early
Christians but that we we don't we can't
know the essence of God I completely
agree with you and the Bible doesn't in
that sense claim to know the essence of
God it claims does it were say who or
where it is I in Christ is it elucidate
like a definition of God God has in that
sense many names
I forget how how I started sorry oh yeah
why do lucky stars main purpose was to
come oh yes
without any yeah yeah you name it
God's main essence and way was from her
is that and say it's not major business
if God is selling us to worship Him
alone Satan's job is gonna be what the
bull of is yeah so this way we're saying
yeah it's a show do you not think as a
Muslim that our Christian friends have
fallen for the trap of Satan maybe tell
me for more show that Satan has come and
made it seem like okay look we need
salvation we need someone to die for our
sins we need so God Almighty came to
earth to take that personal boat and
we're seeing the second commandment the
third commandment is okay I would say
maybe you like the back page for notes I
don't know so so what we're seeing is
that God Almighty is telling us to
worship Him and him alone
yeah and we believe that goes a lot
aligned with our essence because I want
to worship a for example sometimes I
speak to Christians and X Christians who
have accepted Islam or maybe they would
say one thing I didn't know was if you
okay my asking the name of the Father I
ask the Marga in the name of Jesus
okay where is the Holy Spirit coming to
it okay so it's just a bit of confusion
because when we say is our deep essence
wants to worship one or my team yeah ask
him alone yeah go to him alone and
that's what as Muslims were just asked
what is saying let's come to common
terms that we worship God alone I think
I'm the first to like I think it's a
good place to start is good i i'd i and
because i peasant to speak for the
christians but in this conversation i
suppose i proxy to it that a hateful of
idolatry is i mean probably that perhaps
the strongest and most emphatic him in
the old statement very much so and you
know any every time that Israel is
punished is because she and she is
depicted as as as the bride is God's
bride Ezekiel 37 36 particular example
and hence God punishes her I mean and
this is or you know that the famous case
of the golden calf in Exodus I think
Romans is its Romans are the chapter one
or two embarrassing a contra call where
Paul writes right right for rights of
the the proclivity of man to worship
created things he says the men have
begun to worship things that crawl on
the ground created things and then it
ends God has cursed them as a result and
that's true you know there's these are
things that the Christians would share
and I think in that sense the sentiment
is honorable and laudable and in many
ways it's it's what the Jews claim to be
doing now is they would see the worship
of falsely i they would see that the
worship of Jesus as a kind of idolatry
yeah maybe they reject Jesus taught yeah
yeah we affirmed you this well well well
you don't affirm in the way we do we
have been Jesus which we believe is the
real Jesus and you was anything you
would say that's not the really the show
well it depends on on what we think he
said right idea I think the thing so
having said that the the things who
emphasized the suspect is why is it
necessary for there to be a divine
mediator why is it what is the exact you
could say what is the the metaphysical
purpose in many ways yeah of Christ and
I guess one could look at it from this
point of view that one of the things
that the Old Testament is very clear on
and it and forget is the the holiness of
God that is and in that sense also the
other nurse of him that's it if one
touches God's holy mountain one dies if
one sees God one dies as I have says you
know wow is me not appears to him in
life right my eyes have seen the Lord
and
I'm unclean and this is quite right it
makes perfect sense glorifying the
abilities that before in infinite beauty
everything is ugly Shakespeare writes
the more fair and crystal is the sky the
ugly of the clouds that in it fine it's
nice beautiful life I think the thing to
note though then is that how long can
anyone be saved see this is this is
precisely now please don't interrupt me
precisely because of God's thank you
precisely because of God's infinite ood
is holiness and we can argue this if I
were to speak from just purely sort of
philosophical terms if God is the good
right I would say now therefore he is
also infinite right if God is infinite
then by definition we are inadequate
right because that's the nature of any
moral standards relative to the moral
standard we're inadequate and therefore
almost just one kind of quasi
mathematical terms we can never be good
enough and which means that in order to
say that anyone can be saved one has to
either posit a level of good enough
nurse which I think Islam tacitly does
all one has to posit a kind of mediator
and the Christian therefore would say we
posit a mediator wishes to say that sure
sure how is it that I can be good enough
for God well I can't because goddess of
God's holy mountain in the sense of how
can I be pure infinity and in that sense
there's the concept of imputed
righteousness which is the notion of
being in Christ in a sort of
propositional sense if one looks at
Ephesians but chapters 1 & 2
particularly Ephesians 2 verse 9 you
know and this is given to you this gift
from God that you can by grace that no
man may boast I can see again the
emphasis in Protestant denomination of a
lack of works not that one shouldn't
work but the notion that how can you
reach infinitude that this is why the
the mediator is necessary so I guess
that's you could say that the the
necessity of it and the the man being
made the image of God is the the
ontological bedrock on which this
possibility can rest and again again
where Islam Christianity would differ so
I think that's I think I've made my very
profound because you deemed the
necessity of an intermediary yeah to be
the cause because as how holy God is in
His Majesty and we believe that all
beautiful names belong to him and
because as human beings were sinful and
you know we're not at that level and
this is exactly the very purpose and the
nature why Islam came down because god
almighty is saying there's a hadith of
the Prophet peace be upon him he said if
mankind was to commit sins as high as
the skies and the mountains
yea I will forgive every single one of
them as long as they do not associate
partners with me so what could in in in
essence is saying is that look I know
you're a sinner there is also another
hadith of the Prophet who said that the
Prophet peace be upon him said that God
Almighty said to him that if mankind was
not to sin I would destroy them
bring forth another nation that sins but
repents now this is interesting
so is interesting that's really so he's
God saying to me that I should sin the
point here is this what God is saying
that is this I know you're going to sin
okay
the point is this I want you to
acknowledge that you have an Lord thus
forgiving and turn to him so but seeing
I don't want to be infallible from the
get-go goes not saying I want you to be
infallible your goodness sin because if
he was not to sin
yeah then you're gonna be you're gonna
be thinking that shows were a lot of
Christians attribute
Jesus was sinless
why it makes him divine so do you see
that's the reason why God wants us to be
not once us God knows we're going to sin
and that's why it's very important that
God is sending us look you are here you
I still love you yeah I still you're I'm
merciful to you I you don't need to go
through another day to anybody turn to
me alone so do you see why we say that
the human psyche is saying I'm not good
enough
how can i his majesty look at me I'm a
little peasant how can i God say some
words were saying good thing I embrace
you what saying I embrace you nobody
needs to die for your sins
nobody you don't need to go through
intermediaries so this is the I think I
think thank you oh that's very generous
of you
I have enjoyed this conversation
brilliant thank you I think the the key
issue here would be a question of
justice which is why I think I mean it's
often looked upon nobody likes to hear
about judgment and justice say I mean
and anybody that does is delusional okay
what well I mean it is it is a blessing
to know that evil in the world will meet
it's just desert because of God that
doesn't judge but is a god that doesn't
care and this is I think really the
refutation of you know the Atheist
argument says oh it's so unfair that God
judges etc run thank God would do this
is what's the alternative is it God that
doesn't care about just it's not
particularly nice the I think the the
key thing here is that in turning to
Christ and moving to live in him in this
in this way that's I think a few minutes
throughout the New Testament but
Ephesians chapter 1 and to illustrate
and with Christ position particularly
clear in Colossians 1:15 20 is this idea
that if one doesn't turn to Christ and
well and bataille it those that don't
and you know what this is the the basic
task of Christians on earth is to point
to God and his endless love for those
that come to him is that there is
justice done and so
the the idea that one can be forgiven
without justice being done I think would
be my argument for why there's not only
his judgement no it's coming for those
that don't repent but but it's also that
the sins that I committed that I still
commit Christ is taken on the cross but
this is so important that he does take
them on the cross because otherwise
otherwise what's one of my stews the
nature of why just and it's it's it's
you know an absurd scandal that all of
the evil I've done in my life is taken
on taken on by Christ and this is really
understanding that is is is one and
brings forth the sort of devotion that
Christians have to have to go oh he can
but the thing is forgiveness on its own
means that Judge justice my sense but
the thing is I can't answer to the sins
I've done in the sense that I would go
to hell and this I see because I
couldn't be good enough God we go into
paradise is not based on our actions
alone if God doesn't have mercy spite
God's mercy name is very straight so in
Islam we have to put actions in but we
cannot let me tell you very simple
hadith that we'll break it down for you
there was a man who came to God he's
gonna be standing in front of God
Almighty on the judgment and he's gonna
say I want to enter paradise with the
good be stuff man I was very holy often
so many good deeds but it's okay let's
put it into the balance its way up so
God takes his eye foots in the scales
and gets all his good deeds his my our
waste water good deeds is done
meaning the mercy of his eye outweighs
all the bootys he can never repay
he can never make God for the very
vision he has so God sister
to go Hellfire because we did it based
on your you said I want to go paradise
based on my good deeds based on your
good deeds you shouldn't even be going
paradise so yeah we were thrilled
exactly so exactly so what happens is he
says god I'm sorry
please enter me into paradise by your
mercy yeah what he acknowledges is that
if the work she did was good but
acknowledge and think oh it was my good
these are these arrogance because you
can never be back God for the very
vision you have so that was a lesson to
be learned so what it tells us is that
we put the efforts in we pray but it's
eventually by the mercy of God that he
will enter paradise right I mean we
would agree is purely my gracious which
isn't to say that one shouldn't do works
but works are the result of a gratitude
of a right knowledge and so I think
we're here we're here every Saturday
we're at speakers corner every Sunday
doesn't it'll be a crazy there I
wouldn't recommend you to go there
speakers when I'm good speakers corner
and yeah we have really nice discussion
with Jack and we both learn from each
other to next time from Salaam Kona
assalamu alaikum what i'm very care to
thank you jack